we created the today layout so why
doesn't it show up the reason is because
we're using a simple cursor adapter
remember that I creates a list item for
every row in the cursor but it only
supports one item view type that means
that all list items must use the same
layout if we want today's forecast to
look differently we're going to need to
create a custom cursor adapter that way
we can have multiple item view types
then we can have different list item
layouts based on what row of the cursor
we're looking at note that the concept
of item view types applies to adapters
in general not just a cursor adapter if
you open up the documentation for cursor
adapter you'll see that it's an abstract
class
it contains two abstract methods that
you'll need to override the bind view
method as well as the new view method
the new view method knows how to return
a new list item layout but doesn't
contain data yet the binding method
knows how to take an existing layout and
update it with the data pointed to by
the cursor